[Musik]
haben uns jetzt alle mal wieder beruhigt
ja können wir weitermachen gut also ich
bin ja immer ganz happy mit eurer Kritik
bzw kann ich die meiste Kritik auch
nachvollziehen aber was unter dem
letzten Sally Adventskalender Video
stattgefunden hat ist für mich einfach
unglaublich der Kritikpunkt dass ich
voreingenommen bin und das ist sicher
eher wie ein Werbevideo anfühlt als ein
wirklicher Test und dass ich erbeutel
eigentlich blöd finde und bei Sally habe
ich gesagt eine Beutel ist gut sally ist
eine sehr geschätzte youtube-kollegin
von mir die ich persönlich sehr gerne
mag und auch schon lange verfolge ich
bin auch wenn ich mich manchmal so
darstelle nicht das offizielle Gremium
was neutral bleiben muss ich bin ein
Mensch und ich habe meine Vorlieben und
Sally gehört zu meinen Vorlieben und
jetzt einmal zum Inhalt des Kalenders es
wurde nie so dargestellt dass der Inhalt
irgendwie einen krassen Warenwert hat
und man sich da dumm und dämlich spart
ein paar Leute haben in die Kommentare
mal zusammengerechnet was da so an
Warenwert ist und ich würde sagen
ungefähr
100 € der Inhalt waren gute Sally
Produkte ich weiß bei den meisten ist
der Kalender genauso gut angekommen wie
bei mir und es sind nur ein paar
Kommentare die ich jetzt hier gerade
anspreche aber irgendwie gefällt mir
diese Ton nicht bzw diese Richtungen die
diese Kommentare gehen ich habe das
Gefühl es wird von mir verlangt wirklich
alles abzuhelden was nicht 100% perfekt
ist das denn hier
und jetzt geht's los mit dem Video
hallo Leute hier ist wieder eure mal
wann und willkommen zu diesem super
fröhlichen und entspannten
Adventskalender auspack Video heute
packen wir was ganz Besonderes aus und
wir brauchen es auch ein bisschen
bisschen positive Energie ein paar
Strahlungen eure Gemüter und meine
Gemüter zu beruhigen und deswegen
haben wir Kristalle ich muss euch
ehrlich sagen ich habe diesen Kalender
schon geöffnet
drei Türchen für meinen asmr-kanal dann
habe ich aber gemerkt dass die Türchen
viel zu laut sind und das überhaupt
nicht funktioniert deswegen machen wir
ihn hier auf das sind meine Kristalle
wir haben hier Rosenquarz
Amethyst hier ich glaube das ist ein
will Aventurin sagen aber irgendwie
glaube ich das stimmt nicht Tigerauge
verrückt irgendwie ne wenn man sich das
vorstellt dass das die Natur einfach
rausbringt also natürlich muss das noch
geschliffen werden und am Anfang ist es
eigentlich nur ein Stein aber das hat
einfach die Natur gemacht
dann gibt es zu diesem Adventskalender
auch noch ein Buch mit den einzelnen
Steinen der Erklärung der Kalender war
aber nicht so billig und der Shop heißt
dein heiliges Chakra love it der geht
für ein stolzen Preis von
89,95 über die Ladentheke und ich habe 5
€ Versand bezahlt was wir auch besonders
ist ne ich meine brechen wir mal runter
90 € sind 3,75 € pro Türchen guck mal
der ist gar die verkaufen den nur
Maulwurf Geschenke aus der Natur es ist
ein Großhandel für Edelsteine Maulwurf
Geschenke aus der Natur ist unser
Qualitätsmarke für alle Artikel aus
echten Schmuckstein Mineralen Edelstein
die sich zum Verschenken eignen Maulwurf
steckt hinter einem ich dachte da steckt
ein kleiner Laden dahinter nein wir
haben ein Großhändler der das produziert
da können wir doch ein bisschen
kritischer sein aufmachen ist zauberhaft
ich finde ihn sehr schön gestaltet das
ist wie so ein Buch aussieht und ich
würde sagen wir öffnen dann einfach mal
Türchen Nummer 1 ich habe absolut keine
Ahnung was drin steckt Lügen
das geht nur rüber Aqua Marina ist
wieso ist das nicht chronologisch ich
glaube man kann das hier wie so ein
Sticker Heft einkleben Aquamarin da ist
er doch Panini heftiger Esoteriker um
den beliebten Edelstein Aquamarin ranken
sich zahlreiche Sagen und Geschichten
nach einer alten Legende stammt der
Aquamarin aus dem
Schatzkästlein der Meerjungfrauen für
mich löst es immer noch nicht das
Problem dass ich nicht weiß was ich mit
so einem kleinen Stein machen soll
Türchen Nummer zwei Alabaster selinit
sieht ehrlich gesagt aus wir sind
Zuckerwürfel ne der hat hier ein
bisschen glitzi ne es heißt es selten in
der Industrie wird Gips als Baustoff und
Rohstoff für Farben Porzellan Email und
Düngemittel verwendet Alabaster siedenit
ist wie Gips allgemein ein sehr weiches
Mineral Mineral kann deshalb nicht als
Schmuckstein verarbeitet werden ich
klebe das jetzt in meinen Sammelbuch
rein Nummer drei derart den er hat kann
ich tatsächlich schon von meiner Mama
die hat ganz viele Ketten damit und hat
immer gesagt dass sie irgendwelche
Zauberkräfte haben eine dauert los
Kartoffelbrei fliegt ganz schnell los
also erstmal kommt hier wieder was
wissenschaftliches über den wo man ihn
findet und wie er aussieht und sowas hat
wurde bereits im Altertum für
Kunstobjekte benutzt das wird hier total
trocken beschrieben ich möchte die
Heilwirkung haben ich habe ihn im Shop
dein heiliges Chakra warte mal
vielleicht kriege ich den über
das einmal kurz nachschauen ob es ihn
vielleicht irgendwo günstiger gibt und
ich einfach nur einen teuren Shop
erwischt habe Leute
ich wurde über den Tisch gezogen ich
muss mich bei
Marco Schreier entscheiden entschuldigen
ich habe das bei dein heiliges Chakra
für 90 € gekauft ne und der wird auf
Etsy für 54 95 verkauft drei
heilsteinwelt.de wird dafür
44,95 verkauft dein heiliges Chakra von
wegen alter dein heiliges abziehen Geld
abziehen das macht ihr ja also ich teste
den Kalender ne ich habe ihn einfach zu
teuer geschossen aber ich teste ja den
also kostet er 50 € und dann sind wir
bei 50 € nicht bei 3,75 € pro Türchen
sind wir bei 2 € pro Türchen und das ist
absolut in Ordnung ne weil wenn man sich
da in so einem Steinchen Laden Steine
aussucht dann ist das vollkommen in
Ordnung 2 € pro Türchen ist für mich
persönlich finde ich super sage mal ich
wurde über den Tisch gezogen das erste
Mal dass mir sowas passiert müsst ab
jetzt weiß ich auch nicht mehr was
passiert
[Musik]
toll Kristalle guckt euch diese Beauty
an wer Kristall war früher ein wichtiger
Rohstoff der optischen Industrie und in
der Elektronik sehr reine Bergkristalle
wurden früher in Radius benutzt der
Bergkristall bindet Erdstrahlen und
Wasserstrahlen zu einer positiven
Energie er reinigt Geist und Seele zu
dem löst Bergkristall Energieblockaden
auf denn Träger verhilft der
Bergkristall zur gerechten so viel
klaren Entscheidungen lieber
Bergkristall soll ich mir endlich auch
eine Balenciaga Tasche holen oder ist
das Geld Verschwendung
ja weil sie dir Nummer fünf Aquamarin
sieht irgendwie aus als wäre der so aus
Zucker schon unser zweiter der Aquamarin
symbolisiert Frieden beschert geistiges
Wachstum und hilft bei Depression
achtung nicht wissenschaftlich
bestätigte Aussagen hier ne Nikolaus
hallo der Kristall hatten wir doch schon
langweilig oh der sieht aber ganz anders
so cool aus das waren die Erdstrahlen
und die Wasserstrahlen und das Radio
leider kein nikolausstein Nummer 7 auch
jetzt ist ein roter Stein drin von dem
habe ich noch nie gehört
oh mein Gott warum habe ich gerade das
Gefühl dass die hier ein ich habe das
Gefühl also
expectation vs
reality
ja also das sieht aus wie ein
Kieselstein aus dem Garten meiner Eltern
das sieht cool aus special und besonders
sind
es ist einer der klassischen Edelsteine
des Altertums die Sumerer verwendeten
Kanäle für Sie geringe und vor allem für
zylinderförmige Anhänger
alles klar das waren Auftritt der
Lapislazuli
der Lapislazuli habe ich auch noch nie
gehört na wie siehst du jetzt es ist ein
Naturprodukt es ist ein Naturprodukt ich
schwöre euch das sieht aus Tinte das
angemalt hätte also ich finde irgendwie
ja gut ne Naturprodukt das sieht halt
nicht immer aus wie auf dem Bild
Lapislazuli ist ein wirklich
seltene Edelstein er wird nur an wenigen
Stellen in der Welt gefunden und nur an
zwei Fundorten kommen Steine vor die in
den letzten 5000 Jahren als Edelsteine
oder für Schnitzer rein genutzt werden
konnten also ich lese immer nur ein Teil
aus dem Buch vor hier steht immer noch
viel mehr ist schon beeindruckend ich
weiß nicht was ich bis jetzt für eine
Meinung zu diesem Kalender habe aber ich
finde das Buch wertet diesen Kalender
extrem auf ist einerseits das Einkleben
macht ihr Spaß aber auch die Infos die
man dazu hat und ich bin überrascht dass
es halt überhaupt gar nicht in die
esoterische Richtung geht oder um
irgendwelche Heilwirkungen sondern
wirklich
ich nur mit der Geschichte der Anwendung
befasst ja jetzt kommt natürlich die
Nummer 9 und es wird mein Lieblingsstein
drin sein bzw der Stein der irgendwie zu
meinem Sternzeichen und so passt nein
der Alabaster selinit langweilig aber du
bekommst den geschliffenen anglerwasser
selimit ich dachte der glänzt mehr
geschliffen und ungeschliffen
nebeneinander Selenit kann energetische
Prozesse im Körper sowie Geist Hemd und
dadurch für geizige Stabilität sorgen
das Gemüt besänftigen und bei
Hyperaktivität helfen Küche Nummer 10
auch noch nie gehört schwarzer tamalin
Turmalin oh der sieht mega aus der ist
ganz ganz schwarz also wirklich absolut
nichts anderes als schwarzer drin
Turmaline sind eine Gruppe von
Mineralien die in allen Farben des
Regenbogens vorkommen am verbreitesten
ist der schwarz-tomanin der auch sherl
genannt wird Nummer 11 pro Tag das ist
aber auch wieder ein ganz kleiner
oh oh wie satisfying es ist eine
perfekte Kugel eine Jaspis
nein nicht ganz perfekt kommen in vielen
Ländern vor meistens wird er jedoch in
Südafrika Mexiko und in den gesammelt
kommt aber auch in Deutschland
Österreich und Großbritannien vor sowie
in den meisten anderen europäischen
Ländern Halbzeit Nummer 12 Granat du
bist eine Granate also diese Kristalle
enttäuscht mich mehr als mein Ex-Freund
im Mittelalter nannte man den Stein
Karfunkel und nach einer Legende soll er
im Dunkeln leuchten in der 13 ist der
Rosenquarz sie wird er aussehen das
sehen wir jetzt sind
ich sag mal so vom Look ist es jetzt
nicht so die Premium Variante die
Gewinnung von Rosenquarz ist sehr
arbeitsintensiv da das ganze Material
von Hand abgetragen werden muss wenn man
Sprengstoff einsetzt zerplatzt der
Kristalle und erhält winzige Risse so
sieht das aus Nummer 14
Rosenquarz
ey warum können die das nicht mit dieser
Sortierung hinkriegen also das ist die
Sachen wiederholen sich viel zu schnell
ja noch mal Rosenquarz diesmal
ungeschliffen Rosenquarz wirkt
vorbeugend bei Thrombose und Herzinfarkt
alle Informationen wissenschaftlich
bestätigt rosenquad verhilft auch zur
Fruchtbarkeit
[Musik]
ich meine ich finde es ja ganz cool dass
man immer eine geschliffene und eine
ungeschliffene Version hat das war ja
unser roter Feldstein und die
geschliffen uuh guck mal so ein bisschen
Blut ja das ist so ein bisschen cooler
Karneol Wirkung er fördert gute Laune
Lebensmut und hilft das Schöne zu sehen
und dabei mit beiden beiden auf der Erde
zu bleiben
oder was Nummer 16 am nettes natürlich
zum Glück habe ich schon 30 Amethysten
so soll er ungefähr aussehen na da bin
ich ja mal gespannt von der Farbe
vielleicht nicht wirklich aber ich
erkenne hier natürlich
das ist doch nett ja Amethyst ist ein
wunderschöner Violetta Stein der seit
der Antike als Edelstein benutzt worden
ist Amethyst war ein sehr teuer aber
seit dem Bauern in Süd Brasilien um 1860
sehr große Vorkommen entdeckten stammen
die meisten am netteste der Welt aus
Brasilien Nummer 17
der schwarze Turmalin hier bewegen wir
uns wieder beim klassischen Garten
/ Kieselstein
belebend und aktivierend wirkt der
schwarze Turmalin
schon wieder mehr Kristall
ich glaube hier wurde sich vertan das
sieht mir aus wie ein
Lapislazuli der seltene Star Hein so sah
der in ungeschliffen aus so sieht er in
geschliffen aus meine Güte ist das ein
Glow ab
regt mich das auf wir haben den Sticker
schon mal
19 und hier gibt's den geschliffenen
Granat sieht leider immer noch aus wie
so ein bisschen Kieselsteine besonders
Ruder Granat soll positiv auf den
Blutkreislauf und die Durchblutung
wirken und er kann auch bei Erschöpfung
helfen Nummer 20 eine Quarz Geode wow
guckt mal wie es darin glitzert in
dieser Geode ist wirklich die kleinste
Diode die ich jemals gesehen habe 21 in
21 befindet sich der Amazonit und in
Wirklichkeit sieht das so aus WoW
wunderschön ne der wirkt hier ein
bisschen grüner als das Bild aber
trotzdem toll Namen können trügerisch
sein Amazonit ist ein grüner feldspalt
der nach dem Fluss Amazonas in Brasilien
genannt worden ist aber es gibt am
Amazonas keinen Amazonit nein doch
seit 20 noch mal der Amazonit hier ist
einmal die geschliffen und die
ungeschliffene Variante und das sieht
doch wieder aus wie zwei ganz komplett
verschiedene Steine
allgemein wirkt der Edelstein beruhigend
und soll sogar gegen Depressionen helfen
Alarm
Alarm das vorletzte Türchen wir rennen
ganz fröhlich zu unserem
kristallbuchkalender und wir öffnen es
der zweite rote Jaspis fühlte sich
komisch an
der ist ganz scharfkantig die Seiten
sind weich wie Seide und das ist also es
ist ganz ganz komisch und jetzt der
Moment auf dem wir lange gewartet haben
der 24 mann mann mann war das ein
spannender Kalender wir haben so viel
dazugelernt oh
Überraschung Überraschung mal wieder ein
Amethyst
danke vielen Dank und hier haben wir ah
ja ist ja winzig senseer reiner Amethyst
oder achso diese Amethyst wurde
geschliffen wie so ein wie so ein Christ
also wie so ein Diamant auf einem regen
jetzt lass uns mal schauen ja nicht nur
der Steine selten auch die Sticker zu
diesem Stein sind selten das ist doch
nichts durchgerutscht mir fehlt jetzt
einfach ein Sticker das ist wirklich ein
sehr unbefriedigendes Gefühl ja was
halten wir von diesem Adventskalender
erstens ich bin schockiert dass ich 90 €
dafür ausgegeben habe obwohl ich auch 45
€ dafür ausgeben könnte ich weiß nicht
warum ich so schlecht gesucht habe oder
wie ich darauf gekommen bin ich glaube
irgendjemand hat mir einen Link
geschickt auf Instagram und dann bin ich
halt drauf und war so cool
kristalladventskalender und da ich bis
dahin noch keinen anderen gesehen hatte
dachte ich das ist der einzige jetzt
weiß ich es gibt mehrere und es gibt
günstigere von dem also ich finde die
Idee super ich finde auch dass dieses
Büchlein ein richtiger Mehrwert für den
Kalender ist weil hier echt tolle Infos
stehen und man lernt einfach jeden Tag
ein bisschen was dazu das einzige was
ich ein bisschen schade finde ist dass
es immer zwei Versionen von einem Stein
gibt es gibt ja noch so viel mehr Steine
und dann könnte man halt über doppelt so
viel Steine was lernen und hat halt
nicht immer eine ungeschliffen und eine
geschliffene Variante ja das ist so der
Punkt wo ich sage nee dafür würde ich
ihn nicht empfehlen weil es das finde
ich irgendwie blöd ansonsten ich weiß es
nicht was die Zielgruppe für diesen
Kalender sein soll ich mag den
wissenschaftlich geschichtlichen
Hintergrund und weniger dass es bei
Depression helfen soll also wenn sie
damit werben würden finde ich das auch
komisch ich finde das auch extrem
komisch dass es auf jeder Website immer
für jeden Stein da irgendwie angegeben
wird weil welcher Kristall hilft bitte
nicht bei Depression dispoint weil sie
nicht dicker gönnt euch den Kalender
oder einer Freundin oder sonst wem wenn
ihr denkt dass der gut ist ich habe ja
meine Steinsammlung gehabt hätte ich den
ich frage mich ob ich den gemocht hätte
hätte ich den z.B von Timo bekommen und
ich glaube aber nicht weil die sich so
blöd auch wiederholen also dass zwei
Tage hintereinander zum Beispiel
Rosenquarz oder Bergkristall hat jetzt
mal abgesehen davon dass dieser eine
Sticker doppelt gekommen ist und der
andere gar nicht das ist irgendwie
nichts also dann
dann macht er ja eigenes Bild bzw eure
eigene Meinung das könnt ihr ja sehr gut
seid nett in den Kommentaren und für
alle Haider von asmr gibt's jetzt hier
noch mal
oh nee das ist kein schönes Geräusch
oh toll
[Musik]
tschüss